digamos que tenemos una elipse con la
siguiente ecuación x cuadrada sobre al
cuadrado más de cuadrada sobre b
cuadrada igual a 1 y para comenzar
nuestra discusión asumamos que a es
mayor que b y todo esto para nosotros
nos deja saber que será una elipse un
tanto gorda y un tanto corta o bien que
el semieje mayor será el horizontal y
que el eje menor será a lo largo del
vertical y déjame dibujar esto para que
se vea más claro dibujemos la elipse un
poco más gruesa así que nuestra elipse
va a quedar algo como esta forma luego
entonces vamos a dibujar nuestros ejes
este vendría siendo el eje de las x el
horizontal y este nuestro eje y el
vertical
nosotros hemos hemos estudiado una
elipse muy detalladamente en otros
vídeos así que sabemos cómo figurar nos
el semieje menor o el radio menor que en
este caso sabemos que es b que es el
mismo de acá y este es el radio menor
porque es más
y si fuera más grande sería entonces el
radio mayor y por supuesto el semieje
mayor y una propiedad realmente
importante quizás hablando en cuanto a
la elipse será propiedad más importante
es que si tomas cualquier dos puntos que
tú quieras y los miles mires la
distancia de estos dos puntos
importantes con los que empezamos esta
discusión y bueno esto va a ser en
general no solo para este caso
particular vamos a llamar los focos de
esta elipse y ellos o estos dos puntos
son simples a lo largo del eje mayor
donde en este caso sería el eje
horizontal y son simétricos alrededor
del origen así que ya vemos a estos dos
puntos y este primero de aquí le vamos a
poner le llamaremos efe uno de foco uno
y este de por acá va a ser
efe 2
y están señalando nuestros focos y
entonces esta propiedad es la propiedad
fascinante en cuanto a la elipse y
normalmente es utilizada para darle la
definición a la elipse pues si tomamos
cualquier punto
dicha elipse y mides la distancia entre
cada uno de estos puntos digamos que
tenemos dicha distancia por aquí y la
llamaremos de uno y luego tenemos otra
distancia por acá a la cual llamaremos
de dos entonces si tienes cualquier
punto límite es la distancia de este
punto hacia los focos dicha distancia
vamos a pintar dedos de diferente color
para que se identifique que es una
distancia diferente al de uno y estaría
por aquí entonces si tienes este punto y
mides la distancia de este punto a los
focos y las sumas de uno más de dos te
va a dar una constante y dicha constante
va a ser igual a dos y de hecho aquí lo
lo padre o lo importante es que esto es
válido esta suma de distancias es válida
a esa igualdad para cualquier punto que
tú elijas sobre la elipse pues es lo que
nos define en si lo que es una elipse
pero para que esto quede más claro y
estar con la certeza de que entiendes lo
que estoy diciendo vamos a tratar de
probar dicha igualdad
tenemos esto de aquí y vamos a medir la
distancia de este punto a este foco y la
vamos a llamar a esta distancia de 3 y
luego midiendo la otra distancia de este
punto a este otro foco y la llamaremos
de 4 nuestra distancia de por acá de el
punto al otro foco de 4
y sumando estos dos puntos esto sigue
siendo igual a 2 entonces déjame
dibujarlo de 3 más de 4 igual a 2 sigue
siendo igual a 2 lo que significa que de
hecho esto es frecuentemente utilizado
como la definición de elipse donde dice
que la elipse es el conjunto de puntos o
lugares que podemos llamar lugares para
referirnos a una representación gráfica
del conjunto de todos los puntos donde
la suma de las distancias de los puntos
a dichos focos es igual a una constante
y podemos jugar un poco con esto y
figurarnos como serían los focos de la
elipse pero lo primero aquí es sentirse
satisfecho de que la distancia si esto
es verdadero es igual a 2a y la forma
más fácil para visualizar esto es
tomando esos puntos extremos por así
decirlo a lo largo de este eje por acá y
ya justo con esto estamos como afirmando
que dicha distancia de aquí acá déjame
remarcar lo con otro color que esta
distancia más ésta
instancia de por acá será igual a algún
número constante y utilizando este punto
extremo quiero mostrarte que dicha
constante será igual a 2a así que
visualicemos como para esto sería y así
que una cosa más por realizar es que
estos dos puntos o focos son simétricos
a partir del origen porque cualquier
distancia y en especial estado aquí será
igual a una distancia semejante de por
acá entonces puesto que ambos puntos son
simétricos alrededor del origen este de
aquí es la misma distancia de acá y la
suma de esta distancia con esta
distancia larga de por acá que nos
estaría arrojando dicha dicha suma de
distancias de la distancia larga con la
corta y bueno esta de aquí es la misma
de la distancia de por acá y al sumarle
al haber de cualquiera de estas dos
vamos a ponerles nombres para que la
científico e identifiquemos esta va a
ser la distancia gm y está la distancia
h entonces dije es la misma que acá pues
también esa distancia se llama g
cuál es el diámetro entero del eje mayor
de la elipse bueno pues nosotros sabemos
que el radio mayor esa entonces éste
también está y entonces la distancia la
suma de la distancia de este punto de
elipse a este foco más este punto de
elipse a este otro foco es igual a g más
h o esta distancia verde lo cual es lo
mismo que el diámetro mayor de esta
elipse lo cual es igual a 2 amp justo lo
suficiente realmente espero que sea
suficiente para que entiendas esto
entonces ahora lo siguiente que vamos a
realizar es como visualizar dónde van
estos focos o si tenemos esta ecuación
como figurarnos donde estarían dichos
puntos así que la primera cosa que vamos
a realizar es que no nos importa a dónde
a dónde vamos pues será fácil ver estos
puntos pero si tomamos este punto de
aquí decimos ok cuál es la distancia y
luego sumamos esta otra distancia lo
cual también deberá arrojar un resultado
igual
y podemos utilizar esta información de
hecho para ver en dónde están los focos
así que digamos deja dibujó otra elipse
entonces esto fue un círculo así que
este es mi elipse y luego dibujamos el
eje el eje de las x el eje horizontal el
eje vertical
y tenemos la siguiente ecuación x
cuadrada sobre al cuadrado más de
cuadrada sobre b cuadrada igual a 1 para
no perderle el libro a las cosas y
decimos que tenemos estos dos focos que
son simétricos entonces si tomamos este
punto de acá por lo regular los puntos
extremos son muy útiles para tratar de
entender ese tipo de ejemplos no siempre
pero muchas veces resultado y decimos
que tenemos estos dos focos que son
simétricos alrededor del centro de
nuestra elipse entonces éste sería f1 y
f2 y ya hemos dicho que una elipse es el
lugar de todos los puntos o el conjunto
de todos los puntos donde si miles la
distancia de dichos puntos a los focos y
las sumas obtendremos una constante
donde la constante la visualizamos como
2a luego de que visualizamos esto y
tomamos esta distancia y la sumamos la
distancia de acá será igual a 2 ahí
podemos decir que esto es así si
llamamos a esta distancia de 1 y la
distancia de 2
la sumamos es igual a 2a entonces lo
interesante aquí de todo esto es que
esto simétrico cierto entonces esta
distancia de 1 será igual a de 2 pues
todo está siendo simétrico entonces
estos dos focos y sus longitudes son
simétricas y esta distancia de aquí es
la misma distancia que tenemos por acá y
de 1 será igual a a y de 2 pues ya no
hay otra forma también será igualada
puesto que este punto de aquí es el
centro de la elipse entonces nuestra
elipse es simétrica alrededor de los
ejes así que si de 1 es igual a de 2 y
esta suma es igual a 2a pues con esto
podemos deducir que de 1 es igual a y
esta otra también sería igual a entonces
creo que ya con esto es suficiente y se
ha entendido demasiado y tenemos un gran
progreso otra cosa que pensar acerca de
todo esto y creo que estamos listos para
preguntarle respecto a nuestro dibujo
sería qué
es que cuál es esta distancia haciendo
que nuestro es nuestro radio menor y
como ya lo habíamos aprendido es ver y
por supuesto es la longitud focal que
tratamos de visualizar y esto si te das
cuenta lo puedes como decir hey esto
parece el teorema de pitágoras o es algo
parecido entonces tenemos la longitud
focal y vamos a hacer lo siguiente va a
ser f cuadrada más b cuadrada igual a
cuadrada y ahora que tenemos esta bonita
de ecuación en términos de v y a y
sabemos lo que a iverson en dicha
ecuación pues nos los está dando la
elipse entonces vamos a despejar y
entonces la distancia focal sea igual a
la raíz cuadrada de a cuadrada menos b
cuadrada entonces son dos números cual
largos como quieras o tan cortos como tú
decidas tomas la raíz cuadrada y esa
será la distancia focal ahora veamos si
podemos usar esto para aplicarlo en
algún problema donde tendríamos que
preguntarnos por la longitud focal o por
encontrar las coordenadas de los focos
así que digamos que es la siguiente
ecuación
2x tenemos la siguiente ecuación x menos
1 al cuadrado sobre 9
más que 2 al cuadrado sobre 4 igual a 1
así que veamos cómo sería la gráfica de
esto y resulta bastante interesante así
que dibujando los ejes tenemos por aquí
nuestro eje horizontal luego nuestro eje
vertical luego inmediatamente hay que
ver cuál es el centro de elipse y pues
sería el punto 1 coma menos 2 y si esto
te causa un poco de confusión de saber
cómo sabemos que ese es el centro pues
puedes revisar vídeos previos para que
te facilite las cosas entonces x es
igual a 1 y es igual a menos 2 entonces
el centro se encontraría por aquí
después el eje largo mayor de las equis
pues es este número a cuadrada igual a 9
entonces a es igual a más menos 3
así que por aquí tenemos 1 2 3 y luego
menos 3 por acá hay que tener cuidado de
ver bien dónde está el origen para que
no cometamos ningún error a la hora de
dibujar nuestra elipse entonces eso fue
en cuanto a la
delaye hay que checar ahora que su radio
a menor será igual a 2 cierto pues ve es
igual a 2 entonces son dos unidades para
arriba y dos unidades para abajo y esta
elipse va a lucir algo como así y
hagamos la de color verde y entonces se
ve de esta forma y lo que queremos hacer
es encontrar las coordenadas de los
puntos focales donde éstos estarán a lo
largo de este se me el mayor y ahora
necesitamos figurar nos estas distancias
focales y luego esencialmente sumarlas y
sustraer las del centro para obtener sus
coordenadas lo que hemos simplemente
mostrado es que la distancia focal la
distancia focal es solamente lo
siguiente la raíz de nuestras constantes
a ive cuadrada entonces sería la raíz de
9 menos 4 y en este ejemplo nuestra
distancia focal es la raíz de 5 así que
el punto de aquí el que mostramos es el
centro con 1 como menos 2 el centro uno
menos 2
por lo que la coordenada del foco de acá
será uno más la raíz de 51 más la raíz
de 5 menos coma menos 2 y luego la
coordenada del otro foco va a ser uno
menos raíz de cinco menos dos y todo lo
que hace o hicimos simplemente es que
tomamos la distancia focal y la pusimos
desde lo largo del eje mayor entonces
solo sumisos traje esto de las
coordenadas de las equis para obtener
estas dos coordenadas de acá de todos
modos todo esto es realmente necesario
para cuando hablamos de una sección o de
las secciones de cónicas si éstas tienen
estas interesantes propiedades en
relación a los focos y sus puntos en
futuros vídeos vamos a mostrarte los
focos pero de una hipérbola o los focos
de bueno la parábola sólo tendría un
foco y todo comienza a tener bastante
bastante sentido y en nuestros próximos
vídeos estaremos realizando más otro
tipo de cuentas matemáticas en cuanto a
nuestra sección de conectas